just like last year apple has released
four new iphone models except this time
they've completely changed their
strategy for the feature set differences
between them which definitely makes it
even more difficult than last year to
choose the right iphone model so in this
video i'm going to go through 13
purchasing mistakes that you need to
avoid in order to make the right choice
and then i'm actually going to give you
some real practical advice on which one
to buy depending on what you really care
about so without further ado let's jump
right into the first mistake you need to
avoid and that's the fact that for the
first time ever the higher end 13 pro
models actually pack faster processors
than the regular models yep the pros now
get a 5 core gpu instead of 4 cores on
the regular ones and guess what the
performance benchmarks have already
leaked revealing the performance
difference apparently the pro model
scored around 14 000 points in geekbench
5's metal graphics test which is
actually a huge improvement over the
iphone 12 a14 chat but the regular
iphone 13 models only scored around 10
500 points with their 4 core version of
the a15 so if you're into gaming or
anything very graphics intensive don't
make the mistake of buying the regular
iphone 13 thinking that you're getting
the best performance and that actually
leads me into mistake number two if
you're a gamer or someone who really
cares about the display you should
really consider their pro models because
they come with a 120hz pro motion
display which is going to be by far the
most important thing for making your
games feel smooth in the future and it's
actually going to make your phone feel
much more snappy compared to any iphone
you've ever used in the past however
that could actually cause an issue for
some of you that care about battery life
above everything else and that's where
mistake number three comes in don't
think that you have to get the iphone 13
pro model to get the best battery life
because as it turns out the regular
iphone 13 actually has a full hour more
of real world battery life compared to
the 13 pro specifically because the 120
hertz display drains more battery so if
battery life is the most important thing
for you then the iphone 13 might
actually be the right choice or of
course you can just go with the pro max
model since it has the best battery life
out of the lineup getting into mistake
number four this is something that
absolutely shocked me during apple's
event i previously thought that apple
would use the lidar scanner on the back
of the iphone 13 pro models to enable
some of their best new camera features
like the cinematic video recording mode
or the new photographic styles filters
but no apple was somehow able to make it
work on the regular iphone 13 models as
well using excellent software so don't
make the mistake of thinking you need
the pro models with lidar to use those
features now for those of you who are
looking at the 13 pro model specifically
there's another important mistake that
you need to avoid if you care about the
new prores video recording feature
that's coming later this fall apparently
because of the larger file sizes prores
recording will downgrade from 4k to
1080p quality if you buy the base 128
gig storage model of the iphone 13 pro
which could very easily ruin the entire
feature for you so don't make that
mistake if you care about 4k recording
now getting into mistake number six if
you absolutely hate when some of your
apps like facebook reset when you go
back to them then don't make the mistake
of buying the regular iphone 13 models
because they actually only have four
gigabytes of ram instead of six on the
pro models and that extra fifty percent
of ram makes a world of a difference
when it comes to keeping your apps open
so keep that in mind mistake number
seven actually has to do with 5g
cellular speeds because some of you
might be making the mistake of thinking
the pro models have faster 5g
but no all of the iphone 13 models this
year come with the updated support for
more 5g bands compared to last year's
iphone 12 models and if the rumors are
true about the iphone 13 using the new
snapdragon x60 modem then there's a very
good chance that the regular lte speeds
and reliability will improve as well now
for mistake number eight if you're
someone who absolutely hates large
camera bumps that stick out far from the
phone then you need to avoid buying the
pro models because the camera bumps are
absolutely massive just look at this
difference in the footprint of the
square bump itself and now look at the
profile view the camera bump on the 13
pro and pro max sticks out more than
ever before and it'll most likely cause
your iphone to wobble on a flat desk so
avoid that mistake if you hate large
camera bumps now of course there's a
very good reason for the larger bumps
bringing us into mistake number nine
which is thinking that the camera
quality differences aren't that large
first of all the iphone 13 pro comes
with an extra telephoto lens that now
has 3x optical zoom compared to no
telephoto lens at all on the regular 13
models so zoom shots and videos on the
13 pro are gonna be much better on top
of that the pro gets a totally different
ultra wide camera than the regular
models with a much faster f 1.8 lens
with autofocus that takes in much more
light compared to the f 2.4 version
without autofocus on the regular 13. so
the quality differences will be pretty
large especially since only the pro
models will support macro photography
photos and videos with that ultrawide
lens and finally the regular wide camera
on the pro has a larger sensor than the
regular 13 with pixels that are 1.9
microns in size compared to 1.7 and the
lens is also faster with the f 1.5
aperture instead of f 1.6 so if camera
quality is the most important thing for
you then don't make the mistake of
buying the regular iphone 13 models
moving on to mistake number 10 don't
think that you have to buy the 13 pro
max model specifically to get much
better camera quality or other unique
features like we had on last year's 12
pro max and previous models this year
both phones are literally identical
except for the size and battery life
differences that's it now for mistake
number 11 if you need to buy a new
charging brick due to apple not
including it in the box for the second
year in a row do not buy apple's 20 watt
power brick for 19
instead you should be buying anker's 20
watt fast charger on amazon because it's
currently only 11
and it's actually smaller than apple's
version and more compact because the
prongs fold down for portability so i'll
leave a link to that much better charger
down below moving on to mistake number
12 you need to realize that apple has
made the iphone 13 a much better value
compared to last year for the same price
as before you now get double the storage
128 gigabytes which matches the pro
models the 13 now also gets the same
upgraded display with 800 nits of
brightness as the 12 pro models did last
year the 13 now also supports dolby
vision hdr recording at up to 4k at
60fps instead of only 30 and the 13 now
also gets the incredibly good sensor
shift optical image stabilization on the
wide lens as well as the new smaller
notch that looks much better than before
it now also supports dual e sim and of
course it gets a massive 2.5 hours more
battery life than the 12. so don't think
that you got to go with the pro models
to get a nice upgrade and finally for
mistake number 13 if you're upgrading
from an older iphone that doesn't
support mac safe you need to keep a
couple of things in mind if you're going
to be buying a thick case make sure that
it has the magsafe magnets built in or
else the magnetic connection is not
going to be strong enough to work
through that case on top of that you
need to realize that only apple's 15
watt max safe charger supports the
fastest wireless charging speeds all of
the other third-party models are limited
to 7.5 watts so i'm gonna leave some
links to the cases that we recommend as
well as apple's mac save charger down in
the video description below so now with
all of those purchasing mistakes out of
the way we can move on to the buyer's
guide portion of this video starting
with the iphone 13 mini for 699
this phone is basically meant for two
different types of people the first type
is someone who loves the size and feel
of smaller iphones like the old iphone 4
5 or iphone se the second type is
someone who literally just wants the
latest iphone for the cheapest price
possible which is obviously the mini
since it's 100 less expensive than the
regular 13. now the great thing about
the mini is that you're not compromising
on any of the features that the larger
model gets including the same a15 chip
and 5g cellular speeds however i do want
to warn you about the battery life
because a lot of people complained about
it on last year's 12 mini and even
though the 13 mini is improved it's
still not that great so keep that in
mind now moving on to the regular iphone
13 for 799 dollars this model is for
those who want the larger display and
obviously the much better battery life
and to be completely honest the regular
13 gives you the best bang or battery
life for the buck out of the entire
lineup since it actually gets better
battery life than the 13 pro and it
still packs a lot of the nice new camera
features like sensor shift stabilization
and cinematic video mode so this model
is the one for the regular average
consumer that wants the latest iphone
and is okay with paying the extra 100
bucks for a better phone now getting
into the iphone 13 pro this one is for
the kind of person who holds their
smartphone as one of the top priorities
in terms of where they spend their cash
it's 200 more expensive than the 13 but
it comes with a huge number of
improvements like the stainless steel
chassis the much better camera hardware
the brighter display and more and since
there are literally no differences
between the pro and the pro max you
don't have to feel pressured into
getting the max like what happened last
year which sucked for people who have
relatively small hands and if you're
someone who cares about performance at
all whether you like to game or not i
definitely think that you should pay the
extra two hundred dollars because it
comes with a much faster five core gpu
the extra 2 gigabytes of ram and above
all it gets the 120 hertz pro motion
display which i've personally been
waiting for for years this is going to
make the entire phone feel much more
snappy and smooth no matter what you're
doing and it's going to take your gaming
performance to the next level for games
that support 90 or 120 fps so if you've
got the extra cash to spare i honestly
recommend going for the pro and with
that said let's finish off with the pro
max for just a hundred dollars more this
model is basically just for those who
want the larger and more immersive
display size for watching videos playing
games or anything else but on top of
that it has by far the best battery life
out of any iphone ever by a pretty huge
margin two and a half hours on top of
the old 12 pro max which was already the
best in terms of battery life so there
you guys go that was the complete iphone
13 buyer's guide which hopefully helped
you make a decision and if it did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for when we actually get these
phones in our hands and if you're still
a bit confused on which one to buy
comment down below and we're gonna help
you out thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]